llevamos pocas horas en el jarquíbelo
que hemos podido ver es una ciudad que
en parte ha recuperado la vida que tenía
antes de la guerra un ejemplo son los
coches los autobuses que circulan por la
ciudad también los tranvías que poco a
poco están retomando sus actividades de
hecho para el día de mañana está
previsto que una línea de tranvía
empiece de nuevo a circular también en
el barrio de saltisca Norte uno de las
zonas más castigadas sobre todo en los
primeros meses de esta guerra empezada
el pasado 24 de febrero de 2022 Sin
embargo la normalidad por supuesto aquí
aún está lejos se ven pocos niños en las
calles Dos de cada tres niños de esta
ciudad han abandonado sus hogares han
ido de aquí y también es muy visible esa
destrucción hay muchísimos edificios
afectados parcialmente o completamente
destruidos por los ataques por en esta
ciudad que recordemos sufrió un sitio y
que también posteriormente ha continuado
a estar bajo una presión por los
constantes ataques de las fuerzas rusas
un ejemplo es un ataque que ha ocurrido
esta semana ha afectado un barrio del
norte de esta ciudad según algunas
informaciones el edificio afectado
albergaba algunos drones usados por el
ejército ucraniano y también los ojos
están puestos en el norte de la
provincia sobre todo en la frontera con
Rusia a pocos kilómetros de aquí por
algunas informaciones que indican que
unidades militares rusas estarían
aglutinando en esta zona así como
también hay preocupación por las zonas
retomadas de esta provincia Pues también
están bajo presión de las fuerzas rusas
que
están intentando avanzar y recuperar
aquellas zonas que perdieron en los
últimos meses por la ofensiva ucraniana